all right it's time for this week's
sin city chronicles a weekly look back
at vegas history and happenings
and let's start with one of the most
bizarre events in boxing history
[Applause]
mike tyson was disqualified for biting
evander holyfield's ear
twice the incident went down in the
third round and led to
absolute chaos at the mgm grand so why
did tyson do it according to holyfield
tyson bit him because he knew he was
going to get knocked out
and he chose to lose via a dq instead
now
tyson claims it was retaliation for
headbutts that holyfield gave earlier in
the fight
tyson was suspended and fined three
million dollars
for the incident july 2nd 1958 the
stardust held its grand opening
bob hope in milton berle with the big
celebrities in attendance
through the years the stardust was home
to many performers including
siegfried and roy in wayne newton the
hotel was imploded in 2007.
resorts world now stands in its place
and by the way the stardust
took 10 million dollars to build resorts
world
4.3 billion dollars the first weekend of
july in 1969 it was a busy one on july
1st
the landmark hotel opened opening night
it was like a hollywood premiere
the apollo 10 astronauts were the first
to enter the property
followed by celebrities including cary
grant dean martin tony bennett wilt
chamberlain
and members of the la rams then on july
2nd the international hotel opened we
now know it as the west gate
the hotel's first headliner was barbara
streisand and then elvis
arrived at the end of the month and the
king would go on to have
over 600 sold out shows at the
international
[Music]
kendall's favorite wrapping up a busy
weekend in 1969 on july 3rd
sunny and cher made their las vegas
debut at the flamingo
in 1994 the canadian football league
expanded into the united states
in las vegas we had a team june 29
1994 at sam boyd stadium the las vegas
posse had their first
preseason game against the edmonton
eskimos
the posse only lasted one season they
had a losing record
the team they had evening practices at a
makeshift field in a parking lot outside
the riviera
and imagine playing football right now
the heat was so bad that coaches were
allowed to be shirtless
and barefoot last one july 3rd 1979
caesar's palace they had an interesting
headliner rain
they called it the caesars palace flood
of 1975.
over 400 cars were destroyed from this
massive storm
it all went down july 4th weekend
imagine coming outside to get your car
and you're like woohoo
it rained last night veteran city
chronicles for this week
las vegas now will be right